[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy abordaremos el pasado
reciente de mianmar el país del sudeste
asiático en donde el ejército se tomó
por las armas el control del gobierno
este golpe de estado derrocó del poder a
hans anschütz y la icónica líder del
partido gobernante liga nacional por la
democracia los militares la detuvieron
en un alegato de fraude electoral de los
pasados comicios del 8 de noviembre de
de esta manera se derrumban años de
esfuerzos respaldados por occidente para
establecer la democracia en mi alma
también conocida como birmania donde los
militares gobernaron por cerca de cinco
décadas la historia contemporánea de
mianmar comenzó en octubre de 1947
cuando el primer ministro británico
clémont aro y el primer ministro de
birmania 1 firmaron un acuerdo de
independencia para convertir a birmania
en un estado independiente uno llegó al
poder a principios de ese año después
del asesinato del general aung sang cuya
hija aún sang soo choo se convertiría en
años
en una figura política clave a favor de
la democracia pero uno fue derrocado en
1962 por un golpe militar encabezado por
el general ne win y que marcó el
comienzo de 49 años de gobierno
autoritario del ejército en 1988 el
resentimiento hacia el gobierno militar
en birmania se desbordó y estalló en
protestas a favor de la democracia las
calles de la capital yangon se inundaron
de cientos de miles de personas de todos
los niveles de la sociedad birmana
incluso los soldados también
participaron en la protesta en la que
marchaban monjes budistas estudiantes
universitarios trabajadores en huelga y
funcionarios públicos durante las
protestas miles de ciudadanos murieron
por el aplastamiento de las fuerzas
armadas en septiembre de 1988 saw maung
asumió el poder como gobernante militar
de birmania y le cambió enseguida el
nombre al país por el de mianmar y al de
la capital rangún por el de yangon ese
mismo año avanzan succi la hija del
general asesinado aún
y varios otros líderes formaron la liga
nacional por la democracia un partido
político en contra de los militares
gobernantes deseosa de continuar con el
legado de su padre se convirtió en la
secretaria general del partido que pedía
con vehemencia el fin del régimen
militar pero la junta militar puso a la
carismática y popular líder
prodemocracia bajo arresto domiciliario
en julio de 1989 por poner en peligro al
estado en 1990 como resultado de las
protestas se llevaron a cabo elecciones
generales en las cuales el partido de
anshan switch y la liga nacional por la
democracia derrotó al partido respaldado
por el ejército de manera aplastante la
junta militar simplemente ignoró ese
resultado el ejército emergió como el
ganador indiscutible
el activismo político de anza en su
sigue en favor de la democracia y la
libertad le valieron el premio nobel de
la paz en 1991 y numerosos otros
galardones internacionales pero en su
país los militares la mantuvieron en
arresto domiciliario por un total de 15
años hasta que fue liberada el 13 de
noviembre de 2010
ese mismo año mianmar declaró que
celebraría elecciones por primera vez en
20 años de dictadura luego de fuertes
presiones internacionales aunque la
junta militar de mianmar se dio
oficialmente el poder al nuevo gobierno
de thein sein marcando el comienzo de
una era de gobierno civil el país seguía
siendo dominado por los mismos generales
autoritarios muestra de ellos que el
parlamento estaba controlado en un 83%
por militares en servicio o retirados
aliados con el régimen la mayor fuerza a
favor de la democracia del país la liga
nacional por la democracia y su líder
hassan su chip tenían un fuerte apoyo
público pero ningún mandato político en
2015 mianmar vivió unas elecciones
históricas de los 30 millones de
votantes llamados a las urnas
y eligió al partido nacional por la
democracia encabezado por and sun such y
la ley birmana le prohibió avanzan succi
y convertirse en presidente por tener
hijos con otra nacionalidad diferente a
la de mianmar de manera que su amigo y
confidente tea show fue seleccionado
para dirigir el gobierno el 30 de marzo
de 2016
gio se convirtió en el primer civil
elegido presidente desde 1962 sin
embargo sanz anschütz y le prometió a
los birmanos que ella sostendría el
verdadero poder en cualquier gobierno
dirigido por la liga nacional por la
democracia además la nobel de paz dijo
que su prioridad número uno era acabar
con los conflictos étnicos que
involucran a más de 20 grupos rebeldes y
que han mantenido a mianmar desde su
independencia en 1948 en un constante
estado de guerra civil de manera que le
llovieron críticas a nivel mundial por
la persecución del ejército en contra de
la minoría étnica rojilla de credo
musulmán la violencia que estalló en el
estado de rakhine provocó el éxodo de
más de 723
rojillas a bangladesh a partir del 25 de
agosto de 2017 el gobierno que
representa and sun such y defiende que
los rohingyas son migrantes musulmanes
que se originaron en bangladesh y
emigraron a mianmar durante la ocupación
británica así que el ejército ejecutó
una brutal represión de esta minoría
étnica aún así el partido de anshan
succi arrasó en los comicios del pasado
8 de noviembre de 2020 y se postulaba
para mantenerse en el poder por cinco
años más pero el ejército alegado
durante semanas que las urnas estaban
plagadas de irregularidades y aseguran
haber descubierto más de 10 millones de
casos de fraude electoral motivo por el
cual han justificado el golpe de estado
que ha devuelto a mianmar a un pasado
opresor de los militares así llegamos al
final soy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]